we want to remind our viewers that
before that report was released cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell spoke exclusively with
army secretary
ryan mccarthy and the interview follows
a year and a half long investigation
into sexual assault in the military
including interviews with nearly two
dozen survivors
and their families victims told us their
allegations were ignored
and retaliation was rampant we asked
mccarthy about the problem
and where the army goes from here is
there a
sexual harassment and sexual assault
problem
in the u.s army currently the trend is
going the wrong way
and we're going to take some pretty
dramatic steps
in order to reverse this trend do you
think it's clear that
sexual harassment and sexual assault
that there's zero tolerance for it in
the u.s army and the u.s military
there is zero tolerance but at times it
does persist
the soldiers that we spoke with served
at numerous
army installations all across the
country
they expressed a real concern about
whether the army
can police itself can that be done
i believe it can yes you do think the
army can police itself this institution
when it has its focus it's energy
against anything
i believe there's nothing we can't do
the command hasn't been able to do it in
the past these individuals have not been
able to
and they will be held accountable
correct and are there any additional
structures that you put in place
to make sure that commanders are held
accountable in the future
yes this is the message that we're
sending to every echelon below me
which is all of them that this is
unacceptable
as for the timing of all this change
secretary mccarthy told nora he
wanted to take action before january
when president-elect joe biden is likely
to appoint a replacement
because as mccarthy put it he does not
want to pass this issue to his successor
isn't that interesting yeah it is very
interesting i mean those numbers that
mirea
put up on from the report of the number
of women who said they were assaulted
it's just staggering
well i can't say enough about uh nora's
reporting and the investigative team and
the producers who worked with her
they've been working on it for over a
year and a half and kudos to uh
secretary mccarthy because he knew
he was walking into a bus saw i'm not
calling nora bus saw what i'm saying
there is that
she and her team have felt very
passionate about it he knew the
questions were not going to be easy he
knew he had some
very difficult questions to answer and
he still sat down and he seemed
to me personally agreed by it he talked
about having a daughter himself
but i still go back to vanessa guillen
and her family if the family hadn't
spoken up the way that they did they
refused to just let this he was a leader
here he didn't run and hide
when the reporting came out he sat in
the chair and he said we're going to
make changes and the fact that he wants
to do it before january so it can be him
and not the next person
is big and they are sweeping changes